Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
marvel iron heart first look video we just got a
first look at her iron man inspired armor suit and
what's going on with the series so we'll break it
down there are a couple other characters we got to
first look at too the series itself is also going
to explore the balance between magic and science
in the mcu which kind of makes you think of doctor
doom because when you think of man of science
man and magic you always think of doctor doom
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of course i'll do
episode videos for the series when it drops also
explain where it falls in marvel phase 5 because
there are a couple characters that are showing up
during the series that set up later marvel disney
plus series and movies that are happening but
this is what dominique thorne's iron heart armor
is going to look like in in the series they're
calling this the legacy armor so it sounds like
it's going to be one of the earlier versions
of her suit like the bigger bulkier versions
like her mark 1 or mark ii which is why i say it's
probably one of the first versions of her iron man
armor suit just because her traditional comic
book suit is way slimmer and way smaller way
less militaristic looking too you also notice
that this version of the iron man armor suit
doesn't have her trademark heart-shaped arc
reactor in the center of her chest like it
does in the comics that's the reason she's called
ironheart because her arc reactor literally looks
like a heart-shaped you see it during the black
panther wakanda forever trailer like she's making
a new version of her armor suit and it has the
trademark space for the arc reactor that's shaped
like a heart in her chest don't worry i'll explain
where the iron heart series falls relative to the
events of black panther of wakanda forever because
it sounds like it's going to jump around in the
timeline quite a bit but this version of the iron
man armor suit looks inspired by her first iron
man suit that she cobbled together in the comics
with parts that she dumpster dived and collected
from all different sources with zero money like
she was a student at mit when she built this first
version they kind of did a version of that during
the black panther wakanda forever trailer where
she has like her version of another cave scene
like they want to show the clear inspiration from
the iron man movies but it being her prototype
like her iron man mark 1 or mark ii armor is the
reason why it looks so much bigger like dominique
thorne is a relatively small person like she's not
super tall this is what she looks like when she's
wearing the pair down version that they use a lot
of the special effects for like part of the
armor will be practical and part of it will
be special effects but there'll be some scenes
where like they have the entire armor suit on set
you can see where her feet rest really high up on
the shins of the actual armor suit when she's got
the full suit on like the full suit is meant to
be like seven or eight feet tall like super big
the red streaks that you see on here too aren't
blood even though that would be super hardcore
they're meant to be like iron man's hot rod
red color like her iron heart version of the
classic red and gold armor because she got all
the parts for her first iron man armor suit she
actually dumpster dive a lot of the parts cobbled
them together from a bunch of different sources
a lot of the parts were taken from other old
red colored tech like iron man's red color so
that's why the red paint looks so faded because
they're old parts from other tech this version of
the suit looks kind of like a blend of roadies war
machine armor combined with the more slimmed down
and sleeker edges of iron man's armor like she's
got this giant cannon on one of the arms she's
got this huge assembly on her right shoulder but
it's still less weaponized than your traditional
war machine armor suits and that's also why i say
it looks exactly like her iron man mark 1 armor
in the comics because that was giant compared to
her more advanced iron heart mark ii armor because
of where black panther wakanda forever falls in
the timeline and what she does during that movie
creating new versions of the armor it sounds like
a lot of the iron heart series might take place
in the past some people think that it might take
place during the snap i don't know about that
but i do think a lot of it takes place in the
past like they will have flashback scenes to
explain her full origin story like even though
the iron heart episodes will come after black
panther wakanda forever during the series they'll
explain her full origin story her family where
she came from how she wound up at mit how she got
kicked out of mit because they will be doing part
of that during the series too this reminds you of
what happened during spiderman no way home i made
the joke earlier because the whole plot of that
movie spider-man no way home happened because he
was trying to get them all into mit together he
was obsessed with mit because that's where iron
man went to college he had all those scenes during
captain america civil war where he funded all
those programs and all those people's tuition at
mit that'll be really important to remember that
iron man in the past set up all those scholarships
at mit but now in present day because of what
happened during the movie spider-man isn't going
there anymore and by the events of black panther
wakanda forever i believe that riri williams has
already been kicked out of mit or she gets kicked
out during the process of the movie the reason
she got kicked out in the comics was for building
her ironman mark 1 armor suit skipping class and
then causing a bunch of damage and chaos when she
tested it out iron man had backed up his digital
consciousness as an ai in that part of the comics
so this version of iron man basically stopped her
dead in her tracks mid-air during her test flight
with all of his iron man armors just to find out
what she was about whether she was a villain or
another potential protege that he could mentor
kind of the way that he did with spider-man in
the mcu in the iron heart series i believe the
reason she gets kicked out of mit is for getting
caught doing someone else's homework for them and
by that time she's already developed her iron man
mark 1 armor and doesn't really care that she's
being kicked out but in the mcu i think what we'll
explain because riri williams basically comes
from no money there's no way she could pay for mit
she needs scholarship money they'll explain
that during captain america's civil war when
he set up all those scholarships at the end of
his little appearance there when he was showing
off the barf technology she got in on one of those
scholarships during black panther wakanda forever
we just saw the trailer with a bunch of scenes
of her some of it sounds like it's going to take
place later in her timeline you see her making
another version of her armor suit this is what
the suit looks like in lego form like we have the
lego set so we kind of know what it'll look like
you also see shuri as a version of the black
panther so it just confirms that shuri will be
that black panther that you see in the trailer
at the end of that movie i believe that shuri is
supposed to help riri williams create an upgraded
mark iii or mark ii version of her iron heart suit
that'll be more like her trademark classic suit
with the exposed heart-shaped arc reactor in her
chest way less militaristic looking too the other
really big scenes that we got a first look at too
are anthony ramos's hood character going after her
he's playing a version of the hood from the comics
you can see him wearing the trademark hood costume
it's pretty simple costume in the comics he's a
magic user and reportedly during the series he's
going to be the protege of agatha harkness that's
right agatha the harkness coming back in the
mcu because we know they're going to be doing an
agatha harkness series i don't know if agatha is
supposed to show up during the iron heart series
herself or have a cameo scene because i think
it's only going to be six episodes they don't have
a ton of time to introduce a billion different
characters alden aaron reich is also going to be
one of the main villains in the series i believe
he's going to be playing a version of zeke stane
obadiah stane's son which is another connection
to the iron man character in talking more about
the hood character you notice that the act of the
heartness covenant of chaos series is happening
after ironheart i think that's just because
they'll tease agatha harkness during ironheart
like the person teaching hood how to use magic or
he'll be part of her coven and during the coven of
chaos series happening right after that they'll
explain how she escaped scarlet witch's magic
spell that had trapped her in that fake persona
in west view it was meant to be kind of like
a temporary prison we always knew she'd escape
eventually and the reason they changed the name
of act of the hardness of series to coven of chaos
a lot of you've also picked up on this is because
coven of chaos is a reference to her being a witch
a group of witches working together as called a
coven we saw her former coven that her mother led
in the one division flashbacks it sounds like she
develops her own coven again in present day with
other evil magic users like anthony ramos's hood
being one of them and also like i said the iron
heart series is supposed to explore the balance
between magic and technology so there might be
some doctor doom easter eggs but i don't think
that he's supposed to be like a huge villain in
this series or anything like that they're doing
a little bit of the doom war plot during black
panther wakanda forever but he's also not supposed
to be a huge character during that during black
panther 2 he's sort of like the person behind the
scenes pulling the strings because the whole
reason why namor goes to war with wakanda is
because of a very civil war type of reason where
like there's this third party manipulating things
basically pitting namor against the wakandans
i believe all these people in the diving suits
they're looking for vibranium because dr doom is
funding their research he wants more vibranium
and all the technologies that they use to find
this vibranium is developed by riri williams so
i believe the idea is that neymar goes after riri
williams believing that she's responsible for them
uncovering atlantis then shuri and okoye try to
protect riri williams and that's where you get
to your civil war big battle scenes with neymar
versus the wakandans that's also why so many of
these action scenes with the atlanteans seem like
they take place in the cambridge area near where
mit is but the other cool reason why the ag of the
harkness show is called coven of chaos is because
it's reference to chaos magic like a lot of people
were wondering what she meant at the end of the
one division finale when she gave scarlet witch
the warning you have no idea what you've unleashed
you're going to need me what she was talking
about like the thing that's coming was cathode
the god of chaos himself he's the elder god
who created chaos magic in the dark hold he's
the source of all chaos magic he was responsible
for wanda becoming the scarlet witch getting her
chaos magic abilities when she was born in the
series they explained that she was always born
with these powers the exposure to the mind stone
really just kind of turned the volume up on her
dial so to speak they mentioned cathode during
doctor strange two multiverse of madness when
they went to mount one dagore inside the darkhold
temple he's the one who built that darkhold temple
and all the other copies of the darkhold around
the multiverse and all the different universes
are just copied from this one single temple like
this is supposed to be the only darkhold temple
in the entire multiverse because this one scarlet
witch from the mcu is supposed to be the only one
who becomes the true scarlet witch yes i do
believe she's still alive like even though
she disappears here unless you see a body they're
not dead as for riri william's future in the mcu
after black panther wakanda forever i don't know
if she's also going to be in the armor war series
or if roadie is also going to show up as war
machine in iron heart because you kind of expect
roadie to be involved with what's going on with
iron man related stuff he's already appeared in
a couple cameo scenes across different series and
a lot of you also asking if iron man is going to
be featured during the iron heart series because
some of it seems like it'll be flashbacks so he
would still be alive during some of this part
of the timeline or if they invoke him in some
way or has some flashback footage or find some way
to include robert danny jr's version of iron man
but let me know in the comments what kind of
easter eggs do you want to see for robert downey
jr's iron man character how do you want them to
use that character going forward if he's still
dead in present day we all think he'll come back
during secret wars at some point or a multiverse
version of the character but also post all your
reactions to riri williams mark 1 iron man suit it
does look pretty cool but big reminder my she hook
episodes are going to start really soon there's
going to be a whole bunch of daredevil a bunch
of cameo scenes from other characters so make
sure you enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss those everyone click here for my full black
panther wakanda forever trailer video in easter
eggs to learn more about what's going on with riri
williams in the new black panther and click here
for my brand new she-hulk daredevil trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!